I mean, I'm the one that wrote about the painkriotic enzymes last Wednesday, so if you did listen to last Wednesdays call somebody asked about painkriotic pork enzymes and what that was and I explained it briefly, but I didn't wait to our website and
So remember remember remember if you are looking for anything do go to our blog and search for it. So there's lots of information on our blog about painkriotic enzymes and enzyme therapy and enzyme therapy with cancer and painkriotic pork enzymes and Dr. Gonzales and things like that. So I also write heavily about that in our book to have multiple videos about that as well.
I need to tell you that you determined my cancer as to not eat any pork so pork and dairy were or were something that I limited this person for for their cancer.
You also said you test for that meeting the painkriotic enzymes and you didn't recommend enzyme therapy as something that I would need, but I was wondering if the benefits would outweigh any risks having pork and my system. So understand, if you're having painkriotic pork enzymes, that's not like eating pork.
So those are it's just sourced from pork. It's still just that specific enzyme. It's not it's not pork so it's not going to feed your cancer. So let's say you're on a pork free diet.
Should you not take pork enzymes enzymes that are sourced from pork. The answer is my opinion. No, you can take that. There's no harm at taking that.
Would you eat, you know, pork desiccated pork liver if you're on a pork free diet. Still no, that's not an issue. Now, if you're stayed off of pork for religious reasons like your Jewish or Muslim, and is there a harm in taking pork enzymes. No, it's still not pork.
So I don't, you're not deciding if you're having about that, but there's it's not there's not pork in pork enzymes. So you should say, but take you.
Besides the fact that there's lots of enzymes that aren't sourced from pork. So as I stated last week, it's the only ones that we have that are sourced from pork and from pork are that allergy research brand.
And pancreatic pork enzyme product, all our other ones are not sourced from pork. So taking digestime plus taking our pancreas eight X or 10 X, 10 X ultra.
But we have tons of different enzymes on our store.
Benefit for a patient a couple of weeks ago, Megan and I divided it out costs per per, you know, dosage, and they're all pretty much equal. So, you can get one of those enzymes.
If you're concerned about porkists and for religious reasons, it's just fine.